c'est une femme de 78 ans qui comparaît
cette semaine devant les assises de la
nièvre
michel batut rick est accusé d'avoir
assassiné son mari le 24 avril 2016 à
donzy cette nuit là après une dispute
elle là-bas dans son lit de deux coups
de fusil de chasse
l'ancienne pharmacienne reconnaît les
faits et qualifie le drame devant la
cour d'aboutissement d'une vie à deux
qui partait d'un grand amour et qui
s'est terminée très mal
son avocat n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer à
ce thread du procès mais michel batut
rick explique que son geste était pour
elle le seul moyen de se libérer de
l'emprise de son mari
si aucune plainte n'a jamais été déposée
elle prétend avoir enduré pendant ces
quarante neuf ans de mariage de
nombreuses violences physiques et
psychologiques force et d'entretenir un
homme qui vivait la moitié de l'année en
croatie ce quotidien imposant les deux
filles du couple qui se sont portées
parties civiles souhaitent aujourd'hui
en témoigner les filles seront là
effectivement pour décrire ce qu'elles
ont vu ce qu'elles ont subi ce qui leur
a été infligée par leur père pendant
toutes les années où elles ont pu être
présente au domicile
et puis l'emprise que le père tu fait
avoir sur leur maman les jurés auront
jusqu'à jeudi pour tenter d'éclairer le
contexte de ce drame familial et la
question de la préméditation
michel batut rick encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité